the
five main ways that you're going to make
serious bank in your life
if you want to make serious banning it's
not for everybody i get it you know some
people are okay with just not being
there
but as you have come to realize if
you've watched my content or spent any
time in the manual swamp women have very
high expectations of men
and
i've always said this and i'll keep
repeating it none of this should be done
to
attract or appease women this should be
done for yourself because you have
standards for yourself
um i'm a car guy i've always been a car
guy i like fast cars
uh faster cars cost more money cooler
cars cost more money
and the kinds of experiences that i like
to sign up for like car rallies like
exotic car rallies cost money so
that's one of the driving forces for me
like i like hanging out with cool people
and stuff like that
so
the five ways that you're going to make
serious bank as a guy in this world are
going to be let's start number one which
is a c suite job
which
if we're being honest you can't go and
apply for it as a nobody
most people have to work their way up
the ranks and
i started at 20
i think 22 23
because i was living in england 21 22
and um came back around 22 age 23
and i needed to find something to do a
buddy of mine said they were
interviewing hiring at a call center
which was local to me i went interviewed
got a job started out got promoted to
supervisor branch manager kind of moved
way up the ranks by the time i was 30 i
was just under the vp at that point
so
then there's a vp and then there's this
the c-suite jobs cfo chief financial
officer ceo chief executive officer cto
chief technology officer anything with a
c b before it is a c suite job and is
going to pay well into six figures in
some cases seven figures depending on
the comp plan
um but again you're going to have to put
in
probably at least a decade um i would
say more reasonably about a decade and a
half of time
to
get hired for a position in a
corporation because you have to have
experience right like they're not going
to hire some
um you know jimbo off the street with no
experience that just has a nice resume
or smells nice or anything like that
they want to hire you because your
resume like i said earlier people get
hired for their resume they get fired
for fit
c-suite jobs can pay very very well
some of them into seven figures so don't
think for a sec that you can't make
money working for a company you can
but
it's a pyramid right at the very top
there's those c-suite jobs at the very
bottom it's a very wide bottom
okay there's loads and loads of jobs
that don't pay that well where you're
basically doing all the work to you know
provide the value to the top people and
the uh
the shareholders of the business that
get all the value so c-suite jobs is
number one
let's just take these off as we go
through them number two is a
professional of some kind
you went to school for a number of years
you got a professional designation i
know that i poked fun at um you know the
people like to brag about their degrees
framing mahogany with little letters
after the name sort of thing
most of them are [ __ ] degrees if
we're being honest i'm talking about
something like llb okay like a lawyer
your surgeon
um you know you're an in-demand
professional that can charge a lot of
money for your time
um
i don't the minimum wage is here i think
it's around 14 or 15 bucks an hour or
something like that that's how
disconnected i am from being an employer
and having employees it's been quite a
few years for me but
um
these professionals will make
500 a thousand two thousand dollars an
hour for what you know for what it is
they're doing um
i remember i did a
consult with uh my optician's eye
surgery office so you know to fix my um
eyesight surgery is about 10 grand it's
a clear lens
replacement surgery and
the way they run it is they have a whole
bunch of people lined up on the days
that they're doing the surgery and it's
like a [ __ ] processing center
so they do the consults during the work
the week friday and saturday you know
they do the actual surgery and it's like
a five or ten minute procedure for ten
thousand dollars so you work out what
the surgeon's making by the hour
being the qualified professional that
improves people's eyesight okay so
professionals can make quite a lot of
money you're gonna have to put in the
time i don't know that for me eyes like
eyeballs gross me out um i haven't gone
through the surgery obviously because
i've got some hesitation around it but
eyeballs grossed me out i couldn't sit
there with some [ __ ] big-ass machine
and fans and stuff and maneuver them
around to make ten thousand dollars for
ten minutes you know worth of work but
that but that's how it goes right there
are professional designations which pay
very very well so that's number two
again number one is c-suite jobs number
two is um a licensed professional
um and that extends not just a lawyer
surgeon you know there's high-level you
know accounting jobs
i could go on and on and on you get the
idea um there are countries that don't
pay very well like doctors here in
canada like if you're a
a gp like a family doctor you get paid a
lot more working in the states um
certain states you know more than other
you know for example but uh there's
certain countries that just don't pay as
well for certain percent profession so
you'd have to look at
location as well i'm gonna get to the
super chats in
a bit guys i apologize for
rambling a little bit but i want to get
through all these points before i start
going to the chat and stuff um stem was
the next one science technology
engineering mass right
um so
a good buddy of mine is an engineer
of coder
and you could very easily get a job at
any of these high-tech companies you
know the facebooks the googles you know
the youtube sort of things and they pay
700 800 900 000 a year if you're one of
the cedar you know senior like tech lead
coders sort of guys um so there's those
industries there's engineering guys i'm
sure the guys that build the rockets for
spacex are getting very well paid
well into six figures
most people when they go and get their
degrees they don't contemplate these
things they go and get [ __ ] degrees
and it's like look if you're going to
put the time and effort into sitting in
a woke institution where they're going
to shove pronouns and rainbows down your
throat because you want to get a degree
fine but get a degree in something
that's actually useful it's going to pay
you some serious money you know what i'm
saying
so uh number one c-suite professional
stem the next one is kind of a fun one
and it's fame
musicians rappers uh actors
influencers like kim kardashian is a
billionaire
because of her ass and her tits you know
showing it on social media
[Music]
you can become quite wealthy and
influential when you're famous if you
can control an audience if people want
to see you sort of thing
one of the things i talk about in my
course
is the value of building an audience as
an entrepreneur
which i'll talk about more when i kind
of go through all the course lectures
and stuff with you guys during the show
but there's fame um which is pretty
obvious and clear and then the last but
not least number five is
entrepreneurship
i'm a big fan of it um
nothing gives you freedom
the ability to maneuver
and
proper true wealth
i believe as entrepreneurship the other
benefit to it as well is
you can be very rich and anonymous
some people don't want the fame they
don't want
you know people bothering they don't
want to be recognized in public they
want to kind of move about the world
very quietly buddy of mine today calls
me up i haven't seen him in about six or
seven months i thought he was down in
the caribbean but calls me up he goes
hey man i need a favor i gotta i gotta
get my passport renewed um i need
somebody that i've known for a while can
i come up and you know get you to sign
uh you know my photographs and all my
[ __ ] and i'm like yeah you know come on
up i've known the guy for 39 years i've
known him since high school we're
catching up we're talking about [ __ ]
he's always been an entrepreneur we've
gone back and you know fourth over the
years keep it up on skype and you know
we get together and have lunch he's a
great an old old friend of mine too
and um i'm like you know so what's been
going on he's like tell me about this
new business that he's running without
getting into details because he wants to
remain anonymous i know that he likes to
keep a private life he's like yeah you
know we're doing about a million dollars
a day in sales on this um product i'm
like it's pretty good man like you would
never know seeing the guy you would
never know seeing the guy walking down
the street getting out of a car sitting
in a restaurant that he runs a business
doing a million dollars a day okay
and he's like yeah in about six twelve
months we're probably doing about like a
mill and a half a day right so
entrepreneurship
it it is almost limitless when you set
it up right the problem is is that most
people don't set it up right hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you